i'm gonna be completely honest my jaw
dropped
when nathan professed his love to
elizabeth
elizabeth i'm in love with you
elizabeth i love you then not only that
pretty big deal he offered to quit his
job
in the name of love you want more than i
can give you
it would just hurt too much if i lost
you the way i lost jack i would quit
i quit the mounties no to film a scene
that was as intense as that one are you
keeping to yourselves
when you're on set and preparing to do
that or are you kind of like having
conversations about
the back and forth how do you approach
it kevin and i we discussed the scene
and what we wanted to get out of it
um i think we were just like sitting in
a tent together
trying to avoid the the heat and the
mosquitoes that were
swarming us by the pond there were some
elements that were stacked against us a
bit
but um but no i think we've we discussed
it we
spent the time together and it's it's a
very
heartbreaking scene i just had to be
like here's my heart
so i you know distancing myself from
aaron at the beginning would not have
helped me at all um if anything i'm just
trying to like you know
see her again and like you know get back
in that in the rhythm but
the hard thing about that scene was my
very first scene and
and at least one of erin's first and it
was like 10 if 11 like it was just
the climax of the episode so i think we
were trying to like
find the right the the right level um
because we didn't want to go like too
over the top and we didn't want to
you know we didn't want to make it too
cool it was just kind of finding the
right levels
i think we did it pretty intense yeah
yikes i'm looking forward to seeing that
scene oh i bet you
are no when i read it i was like oh man
yeah
it's intense i feel like lucas is the
guy
who does the big move and has the big
grand
gesture and to see something like this
come from nathan i would love your
reaction
i imagined nathan being
sean penn in mystic river but instead of
saying is that my daughter in there
i love you he said my daughter in there
he said my daughter there i think nathan
is the sean penn of hope valley
that's a great thing to say nice thank
you
aaron of course elizabeth has
a real strong reaction to hearing such
big news from nathan can you kind of
walk me through uh what was going
through her mind in that moment
there's a line in the scene something
like if i stay it'll only make things
harder and i think that was
probably the the mantra that was running
through her head that that sense of like
this is an impossible situation i'm i'm
just
trying to follow my heart my gut here
and make a decision and
and you are making it impossible so so i
think that the goal there was really to
just
extricate herself and and even when by
sitting up on that horse and
kevin cried out the way he did as sean
penn or
sean pat yeah um it was just it's
heartbreaking
i mean he did such a great job and um
you know thankfully we were able to get
the horse to cooperate
and it was just get out of there and
kevin
this big nathan moment did that surprise
you when you read that oh wow this is
where
this is where this is going not only the
beloved mission but
but saying i'm willing to drop the
mounties if it means we can be together
yeah yeah absolutely i remember reading
the first two and i was like wow this is
very out of his character um
but you know it it goes back to that
point where his his life kind of changed
a bit at the end of season seven where
he's really kind of
um or reorganizing his priorities of
what he wants and then what he's willing
to give up to get it so
it did make sense and it just did not go
the way i think that he wanted it to go
well there's still ten more episodes
yeah that uh it can go either way
uh chris we've only seen some footage in
trailers but we know lucas is
you know he's always got his his game on
point we see him
like gently placing his hand over
elizabeth's we see a beautiful
picturesque picnic
now that we know nathan is kind of
performing at a 10 on the confidence
level
what is that for lucas and and his
approach to accordingly i think
the stakes the stakes are a lot higher
in season eight rather
than flowers being the kind of the
biggest gesture that we saw in season
seven
it moves to a date or you know
physical contact a hand on a hand
something like that and there's a there
are a few moments that
a few events that lucas tries to
orchestrate you see uh
lucas open up a little bit and show a
bit of a sense of vulnerability
i feel like there are several um several
picnic
or outdoor eating scenes
that's called a picnic ah
i outdoor eating several of those